mistakes writers often make in pitch
meetings the first mistake is to be
boring do not be boring have energy have
enthusiasm not over-the-top not scary
not I know somebody who had a great
meeting set up she knew that she she was
you know highly recommended but she was
so nervous and she was so over the top
that they just went oh my god and they
passed on it of course make it a
conversation I said be prepared be
prepared but don't memorize it look read
the room look at people's eyes look at
their body language if they are drifting
off then say do you have any questions
bring them back in or know that the road
you're going down is not meeting with
very much response so try a different
part another mistake I see a lot is
giving a laundry list of characters
there's Steve Miller
he's a accountant he's a uptight
accountant his wife Stephanie Miller
she's a quirky housewife where all they
do is just list names first and last
names nobody cares they wonder who the
character is not what their name is and
what their occupation is a little bit
about their occupation but more who they
are as a character rushing through
things is bad giving too much
information is not good giving every
beat of a project unless you're there to
do that and mostly pitch meetings are
not that is overwhelming people's eyes
will glaze over it's terrible I know
writer who this isn't true anymore but
this was a while back came into a
meeting and the executive that he was
meeting with said oh what do you like to
watch and he said I don't watch
television or somebody who only says if
they're meeting in a network and they
only say you know Netflix shows or HBO
shows then really you're sort of you're
sort of peeing on the work I do you know
what I mean so be respectful I like what
you said about what was it sized up the
room or read the room the room that's
beautiful read the room and see how you
react how people are reacting to you if
you if their eyes are glazing over if
they're tired if they're leaning forward
you're doing really well if they're
asking questions you're doing really
well if they're leaning back and you see
their eyes glaze over if the room is not
responding and you've tried a couple of
different ways wrap it up wrap it up and
just say thank you so much and leave so
better to keep them wanting yeah then
kind of being that person that stays to
the end of the party exactly saying can
I help clean up no don't be that person
you